so Alex what do you do here at Khan
Academy good question I've done so many
things generally I work on making
exercises and other parts of our content
more interactive that means these are
can actually do something with them and
they're not passively watching or
passively reading and and what is that
on a day to day basis on a day-to-day
basis it's fixing a lot of bugs it's
working on a lot of projects that
sometimes test small changes and
sometimes test really big changes how do
you test a small change you Jenna small
change by making it for some percentage
of our users but not all of them and
then seeing what changes and metrics
results also be asked questions I show
users these days like hey did you
actually get something out of
khanacademy today and that really helps
us answer that question as well say so
you make like a small change and if
people say more more like and say that
helped them or if they're more likely to
spend more time learning or whatever it
might be yeah that's all the time what
are you working on right now right now
we're working on some changes to the
video page actually all tutorial pages
bringing back the practice button that
we used to have which said hey this is
the video how about you actually
practice this concept which is fun and
that should get a lot more people to
click on exercises in line on videos
another one is just changing our layout
to be more you too [ __ ] and seeing how
that affects us because one of the
results of his research was that a lot
of people are very familiar with YouTube
as a layout and anything you can do to
be more like that unless our own special
playing the better for familiarity and
what were you doing before you came here
before I came here Amelie before this I
was working at a peer-to-peer carsharing
startup called get around and the whole
idea there was if you had a car and you
didn't want to well you wanted to make
some money off of it when you weren't
using it which is you know ninety
percent of the time if not more you
could rent it out to their people and we
would take care of the insurance we
would take care of finding people who
want to rent your car
and yeah that works pretty well these
days they put it to making it so you
pretty much have to put your car with
them again around system if you're gonna
do it and then also schedule your own
time on it separately doesn't makes it a
lot easier for other people to get it
instantly it's a scheduled time on your
own car yeah i see that makes sense it
makes it easier to utilize and what
other I mean I distinctly remember even
when like you were interviewing him you
were also a skilled fighter yes I
noticed that you're interviewing me by
yourself this time you don't have Sean
Tania's backup that's right john is a
black belt so I felt very safe with him
around how do you feel now I feel
comfortable okay you are wearing
somewhat camouflage army pants which
makes you but yes yeah I'm a ninja shirt
but yes it's fun uh yeah it was a little
a wonderful contrast I think I remember
telling you about this to taking tech
window and then taking something which
is much more of a combat and quickly
resolve conflict sort of quickly herself
kozilek by winning yes or getting
anything yeah so what was that what was
it was this other non Taekwondo thing oh
my god and so you are like a Krav Maga
person skilled person um that's not
something I've done in some time I was
focusing more weight lifting recently i
see so but it's a wonderful compliment
to that actually it really gets your
blood pumping and exhausts you in terms
of cardio and i remember when we
interviewed you like it like it was
myself and shot to do in the room and
when we learned about this i asked you
do you think you could take both of us
and you didn't even think about it you
see that was very impressive you seem
very confident it's it's a good thing to
be in confidence so what made you come
to Khan Academy so it was after I'd been
at the car sharing company for a while
realizing that hey this is this is a
good problem that I really hope that
somebody solves it doesn't have to be me
so then it was very much like okay
looking at all the space of possible
problems and
at the companies that are to need to be
solutions to that where you actually
want to go so Khan Academy was the place
where of all the education all that it
takes places I've seen and I like Flickr
on all of them basically was the one
that seemed to most willing to be to
attack the problem from the lowest level
possible to look at the building blocks
of what education is to look at them
discard parts i didn't work to build
upon other parts that seem to be working
better and to really innovate at the
core of it instead of just taking
existing things and putting them online
like so many other companies are doing
which is great and useful but it's also
not the place I wanted to be at and then
we have since you join kind of what's
the experience been like what's may be
surprised you give me a little bit more
of a prompt than that yeah just like I
mean just described kind of what it's
been like last you know it's been what
over to you two years a two years ago
yeah yeah yeah that's a question what's
it like to work here so assuming you've
done sir all these interviews you
probably hear that one of the top
reasons is the people and that was one
of the mean thought processes for coming
here I was really motivated to try to
find a group of people who are equally
motivated to work on stuff and very good
at what they do and i found that and
that's been by far one of the best
things because working with people who
actually know what they're doing and
care about what they're doing was
wonderful and it was definitely missing
some of that i guess in general
throughout life until I got here so
right now just your crop maga got on the
camp active so those are good thing but
there's also something i guess it was
expecting and i would have been
disappointed if i hadn't found here
surprised it was interesting to realize
how
how Khan Academy differs from being a
normal tech company in the sense that
there's basically half the company
devoted to all sorts of other things so
not product but I guess product market
fit related things partnership sort of
things outreach internationalisation all
sorts of things that require very
different skill sets from a designer
developer product manager content
creator so that was interesting and it's
also been interesting to talk to these
people try to understand what they do
more and also understand what
experiences they're having one of the
things I'm sure you have heard enough
about by this point but has been that
experience working on the different
sides of the house has been actually
fairly different over the last year too
yeah yeah no you're right and you know a
classic any for-profit company they
would just say okay whether it's on the
product side or on the programmatic side
you like okay where are we going to find
revenue while our Charter our mission is
actually maybe to actually target the
places where there aren't revenue
because that's where P the people aren't
being served whether it's a developing
country or whether it's the inner city
or someplace oh yeah there's a lot of
programmatic work on how do we make sure
we reach those folks who frankly you
know the market is failing in a lot of
ways and that's a very high question
that is a very hard question it is
literally like the product market fit
trying to find out across multiple
markets with a product that is evolving
and yeah you can only pull it in so many
different directions at once yeah so you
can't make it try to fit everything ya
know agree and what would you know what
advice would you give to someone you
know in middle school or high school who
kind of wants to do what you do one of
the wonderful things about the internet
today and all the stuff that's out there
you don't have to wait until your meat
or as old as I am the ripe old age of 25
as old as you are to be doing what I'm
doing or to be doing all sorts of other
interesting but related things the
simple answer is just go out and do
stuff if you want a little bit more
direction than that
find some way to get some mentorship in
terms of encoding since that's my main
specialty and there's ways to find that
in open source projects to there's ways
to find that and dedicated programs that
exist especially around you into the
area but you really kind of want to get
over that initial hump where you can be
you can feel confident in your
productivity and I there's something
that you don't know how to do but you'll
learn it and you'll get there and that's
that's one of the useful forms of
confidence to have because let's see you
be like okay I can choose any of these
equally challenging and daunting tasks
and know that i will make a lot of
progress on them and very likely
completely succeed instead of being like
I don't know how to do that and then
shrink away from that in fear which is
bad so that's really the most of it you
want to get to that place where you have
that confidence and there is an initial
bit of work should become good enough so
that you have that confidence in
yourself you want to try to get over
that as house if you would really just
go up and start making stuff and it's
somewhat for your lyst fashion you know
go make make mistakes it's never been
easier frankly you can make things that
affect real people you can make apps if
you want you can make games you will
learn a lot if you make games especially
like all the graphic stuff that's so fun
oh yeah so now but that's yeah that's
how I started to yeah it's just how
standing and frankly even to this day
making pretty things appear on screen is
a wonderful little video yeah so what
are you excited about right now as
regards to Khan Academy seizure or just
oh I guess are anything but you have it
okay so let me answer the question mark
okay specific reference frame first so
what I'm excited right now about is
after kind of going through a series of
existential threats essentially you
could say okay we admissions to combat
product not feeling engaging enough or
there was another one just like the
whole organization into tutorials was
another thing and now it seems to be
okay let's put the content front and
center and make more of it and be good
at that which was always my suspicions
as to how do you make Khan Academy win
in a sense that when is delivered the
most value to those people so I'm really
excited for that in general specifics
about just making more content in more
areas and trying to be more deliberate
and how you both how you create that
that what granular do you create that
how you package that up all of that has
needed some thought for some time now
and I find it all so now we're actually
tackling that out so I don't work really
a thing that's what I'm excited about
that's in other news it's really always
interesting to kind of keep abreast of
trends and what's going on like I'm sure
you're living here in the Bay Area it's
super obvious that oh hey you know like
the maker movement is something that has
is very solid right now and you've been
able to track it over like the last 5-10
years and see how one form just like a
tech shop here the detection shop there
to 3d printing everywhere you can look
at oh well I guess II golem drones but
quadcopters was used to be the main
thing that you would get rise of
consumer vr that's fascinating frankly
and virtual reality yes yes on actually
affordable and you can do something with
the level and having tried it the the
main thing there is a sense of presence
that you are actually transported
somewhere else that's powerful and for
people haven't experienced it it's a
very very interesting feeling like you
put on your like I'm not in this office
I'm why am I powerful and there's a
whole set of things that are you know
need to be tried there need to be tested
and entire rolled of discovery
essentially sometimes it like people
might say like oh man oh super easy to
like make stuff an app store one that
was a small place well if you're looking
for small places that are getting can
see lots of growth
i would say vr is one of those places
and yeah and this time it ties back to
the advice about like where do i what I
say to kids want to do cool stuff it
helps to be like one of these inflection
points when something is like gathering
steam and going to become big but also
like don't just do that just because
that's going to happen do it because you
want to and it's really easy to be like
oh well you know I'm going to do this or
this because I think you can make me
lots of money now but if you don't have
the motivation for it you're going to
quit it long before somebody else does
ya know that's very good advice well
thank you for being part of this crazy
adventure thank you